he did Megan Markel's makeup for years
now Spencer Barnes is revealing the
future Royals favorite products and
giving us a step-by-step guide to
getting her look on spillin the royalty
[Music]
hi everyone I'm Marisa Runyon senior
style editor here at Entertainment
Tonight and I'm here with Spencer Barnes
makeup artist extraordinaire today he
will be creating a beautiful wedding
look on me in the style of Megan Merkel
we are so excited to hear all of your
inside tips and tricks on how to get
that beautiful natural dewy look that
she's known for we want to make sure
that the skin is well prepared the eye
area I'm going to give a little bit of
eye cream this is just a way to freshen
and hydrate and make sure that the
makeup is not gonna be creeping or dry
just a nice sheer layer of eye cream in
the eye area
this is one of my favorite products by
Kate Somerville it's called the instant
thermal quench liquid lift whose all
have you closed your eyes it's got a
cool feeling to it so just be ready for
that and it it's great because it has
hyaluronic acid which you might have
heard in the press yes it gives an
instant cool tingling effect and what
this does is it holds a thousand times
its molecular weight in hydration so
it's very hydrating but also very
lightweight so this will just give you a
quick almost like an oxygen facial and
allow your skin to soak in some extra
hydration it's cool and tingly and it
smells like keep Sunbury like a soft the
skin though is really her secret I think
she's she's learned that by keeping the
skin looking luminous and fresh and even
and hydrated
she looks youthful she looks healthy she
looks more natural too
[Music]
so now I'm gonna jump in with one of my
favorite products for the lid this is
beauty by puree I soaked and this is her
nude tone so it's a very Universal shade
what this does is it perhaps the lid or
makeup particularly eyeshadows and helps
them stay in place all day go ahead and
look up I'm also going to do a thin
sheer layer under the eyes some people
will use a concealer on the lid and that
can work too this is formulated
specifically to be creaseless and stay
in place I like using the clay to put
one in place of this if I don't have it
I'm gonna use matte eyeshadows to
structure your lid you're basically
playing with light you can add a little
color but you're beginning to structure
the lid based on where you put
highlights and shadows so we're using a
basic nude palette with a little bit of
warmth there's some peaches some Browns
some topes you want it to be like
effortless chic polished so I'm using a
flat round brush and I'm applying some
topi nudes a little bit of caramel E
warmth and then a little bit of peachy
tones to create a wash across the lid
I'm blending it from the lash line into
the crease and then softly blending so
the arch stays open and clean now I'm
going to bring in a little bit of light
on the inner corner of the eye when you
work with pearl tone or shimmer tones
you'll you'll come to know that where
you place them will have an elevated
ability to catch the light so be
selective where you put those I'm using
a little bit of sheen on the inner
corner of the eye you know being that
megan has her beautiful brown eyes if I
were to use a little color I would say a
subtle sheer lavender with a little
Sheen or a soft pink those would both be
really pretty peachy tones gold tones
those are all going to pop and
compliment her brown eyes in a natural
way when I think of wedding makeup I
like to keep the eyes bright I'd open
and fresh even though you may want them
to find so I am applying a little
neutral shadow underneath and I'm
keeping it very tight
now I'm going to add a little bit of
subtle Sheen right in the under corner
of the eye can you see we haven't done
mascara yet but when you have lash
mascara on the bottom and you get that
defined separated look having something
with just a little bit of reflection
behind it will help pop the lashes this
one is the unzipped lorac it's one of my
favorite neutral palettes there's a
collection of maps as well as some
machine and luster now I'm coming in
with a little bit of this matte tone
under the arch and just a subtle bit of
sheep the brow bone is a great area to
give a little architecture to and help
it look a little more raised and
dramatic by applying a light highlighter
also the inner corner of the eye is
another area I added a little highlights
so now I'm going to define the lash line
on the top with a soft copper tone eye
pencil and I'm working it right into the
lash line and then gently lifting on the
outer corner and then we're gonna blend
it smudge it I don't want to get too
dark on the eye area but I do want a
little bit of extra depth at the lash
line this will help the lash line look a
little more dense and full I'm gonna add
just a bit of like a Mothe tone yeah now
I'm gonna come back over this liner with
just a hint of plum right at the lash
line I'm gonna connect your lower lash
line to the top follow it up and in a
moment we're gonna do some lashes then
I'm going to apply a light thin coat of
liquid liner to just polish and tie it
together if you're doing pictures or a
wedding you're gonna be on camera or
with a lot of people all day I like to
use a brow gel this one's got a subtle
tint this is a product that gives the
brow some state power so I like to brush
the front of the brow up just so we see
a little bit of those brow hairs
gives a little texture to the edge of
the brow and then smooth the tail and
arch into place that's a good luck
and what's this product for using
benefits gimme brow she has killer
eyebrows like the ones that everyone
wishes they had let's do some lashes
often with photos particularly a
person's natural lash line it's it
doesn't capture as strong as it is with
the naked eyes so it's softer so by
adding lashes you're actually giving
back what would be taken away by say a
flash in a photo
these are individual flares and they're
not free and I'm working with short and
medium and that way you know the ends of
the inside and outside corners are a
little bit shorter and maybe the the
middle third where the arches I make
those a little longer it just gives it
that kind of doe-eyed shape just look
downward and these going really easily
her eyes actually look bigger now
because they look more open want to do a
thin sheer layer of eyeliner so just
look down and I'm gonna gently lift and
notice how I'm holding this at an angle
it gives me a lot more control a little
mascara lash mascara to blend your
lashes and the new lashes together but
downward and I don't want it to be too
thick or heavy but add some extra
definition kavanah Quan has this
incredible product the sensual skin
enhancer and you might have noticed I
warmed it on the back of my hand and
then I'm blending it gently it's a it's
a very full coverage product so I use
very sheer layers and what that does is
it gives me maximum coverage with very
lightweight layers yeah the heavier
makeup looks it will start looking cakey
you know and you know it wants to look
cakey it also will start accentuating
micro fine lines expression lines
because it settles so you don't want a
heavy if you have to wear a lot to get
the coverage I would recommend finding a
different product you want to go sheer
as possible but yet giving yourself the
best coverage you can get without a lot
of products this is the japonesque
sponge very similar to the Beauty
Blender I
damn bring it out and then I blot the
face and that pulls out any excess
product we don't want any extra product
sitting on the skin or settling into
pores or settling into fine lines I'm
gonna do a light veil of powder to set
what we just did in place when I've
worked with her I've given her very
subtle contour but she doesn't needle
Wow and not everyone does you know so
that's part of the assessment is going
how will this help help the overall look
or will it just muddy it up will it make
it heavy this is one of my best kept
secrets and longest hard-working basic
products it is a product that I know
Kardashians and JLo have been using for
years it's contour number one by Ben Nye
it's the color of a shadow it's a soft
Toby gray ashy Brown and that is exactly
what contour is about it's about
accentuating shadow planes by adding a
little more intensity and that gives you
that sculpted defined look so we're
doing a subtle bit on the cheek blending
it out what light does is it flattens
and takes away any structure so by
adding in a little structure you're able
to keep the face looking defined and
dimensional so that's the real idea just
a little by the hare way no sheep zone
I'm the littlest bit on the jawline
these are just natural shadow places too
so highlights are the reverse of a
shadow so I'm gonna take and do a little
bit from the upper cheek plane bridge of
the nose and on the tip just a little
bit you know sometimes I like a little
bit of this on the top of the lip that
Cupid's bow this area is a look of youth
you can also do a little bit on the top
of the chin but I'm being very light
handed a little bit on the upper cheek
plane by the eyes maybe a tiny bit under
the brow arch again now we're jumping
into cheek I'm gonna have you smile I
want a little
a natural glow on the cheek so I'm using
this shimmery peachy pink tone and the
reason a smile as good as it helps you
see where the cheek this is the apple of
the cheek that's where you want to put
the color and then gently sweep back
towards the hairline she looks best with
neutral tone lips if there was every day
you were gonna wear a little pink and
your lip weddings are good now I'm
missing in like a neutral lip liner and
the color combo it's kind of a chubby
stick that gives us a little extra color
and coverage so I just want to mix in a
little bit of pink tone I think with
this it'll be flattering to have just a
little bit of pink nude tone we kind of
think of head to toe beauty so for the
legs and the arms this soft body weapon
gives a perfectly silky smooth finish of
hydration but it dries down to a silky
dry finish so I like to use this on my
girls on their decollete their shoulders
arms legs Spencer thank you so much this
is gorgeous am i giving you full Megan
we're full right now yes we'll see the
final reveal go ahead and check that out
oh my gosh I wish I had someone to go to
the hey this is so beautiful thanks for
watching spilling the royalty posts new
content every Friday
[Music]